foreign
so
one minute countdown one minute
much
20 seconds
five seconds
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's news conference chief james
raymer will begin followed by staff
superintendent lauren pogue and then
mayor john tory will also provide
remarks they will provide an update on
the services operational plans for this
weekend we will then follow with
questions
good afternoon and thank you for joining
us today
i hope i will provide an update on the
police planning for the weekend
and will then invite staff
superintendent lauren pogue to say a few
words
mayor toya tori has joined us today in
headquarters and will also provide some
remarks
as you are aware the toronto police
service along with our city and
emergency response partners and the ttc
is preparing for a convoy for freedom
protests and locations around the
greater toronto area including our
downtown core tomorrow saturday february
5th
our objective
objectives will be to ensure the public
safety and to limit disruption to the
city and its residents as much as
possible
we have plans in place and we continue
to communicate with a very group of
organizers of these protests
the services required to facilitate
peaceful demonstrations
this will be balanced by our priority to
ensure public safety
to protect hospitals and infrastructure
and the city's emergency response needs
the public should expect a large police
presence in and around the downtown core
and other areas around the city at
different times over the weekend
the service will manage these protests
as best we can with the intention to
limit disruption
but our number one priority will be the
safety of the public these events are
always fluid and dynamic and we will be
doing our best to respond quickly and to
communicate any important information to
the public on a timely basis
we have done our best plan for this
based on all the information we have
our approach will necessarily evolve
based on what we see in real time
as always
we ask for the city's patience and
support as we do our work to serve and
protect
the service will be prioritizing
emergency access routes to hospitals to
ensure patients their families and
health care workers are able to access
the hospital safely
road closures have already begun and
will be in effect to eliminate potential
disruption to patients and health care
workers who need access to hospitals
anyone
who attempts to disrupt hospital access
and roots of emergency operations
including ambulance fire or police
will be subject to strict enforcement
as we work to protect the public we
again ask for your cooperation
and your patience as you may experience
traffic delays in the downtown area and
possibly extending into other areas
we recommend that the public avoid all
demonstration areas if possible and to
consider using public transit if they
must be in those areas
the service will provide regular updates
to the public through the weekend and
this will be provided by staff
superintendent lauren pogue
i'd like to invite uh lauren to say a
few words now
thank you keyframer
as the chief has mentioned our members
have been working tirelessly over the
last several days to develop a plan that
prioritizes public safety and as limited
disruption to the city as possible
here is what we have done so far
we have deployed a greater number of
uniformed police officers to the
downtown area
we have put road closures in place for
the areas of university avenue and
college street
we have implemented parking restrictions
to the area surrounding university
avenue
we have installed additional cctv
cameras that will be used to monitor
police operations and assist with any
potential investigations
and officers assigned to respond to
protect activity have been directed to
have their body-worn cameras turned on
for the duration of the event
we have worked with our public and
private sector partners such as the city
of toronto emergency response and ttc to
use all of the resources that may be
available to us
i will reiterate what the chief said we
will be prioritizing emergency access
routes to hospitals and anyone who
attempts to disrupt hospital access
and routes of emergency operations
including ambulance fire or police will
be subject to enforcement
we are prepared to monitor events across
the city 24 7 and deploy additional
resources if necessary
we will provide timely updates through
the media and social media so the public
can be as informed as possible
i will be making myself available as
needed throughout the weekend for
updates as well
i'd like to close by thanking all
members of the toronto police service
especially the downtown divisions and
our emergency management and public
order unit who have taken the lead on
the planning for this weekend
we know the increased presence of
uniformed police officers can be
unsettling but we want to reassure the
public that we we are doing everything
we can to keep our city safe and secure
thank you
and now mayor tory
well good afternoon and i want to say
thank you to chief ramer and staff
superintendent pog for this update i
think it is important that the public
has as much information as police can
provide ahead of this possible protest
and throughout the weekend and i'm very
grateful for the efforts being made to
keep everyone informed
i'm here at headquarters today police
headquarters to show my support as mayor
for the week that the work that the
police are doing to keep people safe
this weekend and to prepare for this
weekend
our city is no stranger to protests
often significant large protests
throughout this pandemic we have seen
protests happen on a number of different
occasions and on a number of different
issues including regular weekly protests
where many gather to object to public
health measures into vaccinations i
don't personally agree with all of the
views expressed by all those protesters
but i respect the right of all canadians
to peaceful protest
so we've seen many peaceful and
respectful protests in our city and it
is my hope if people are determined to
gather to protest this weekend in our
city of toronto that a commitment to
respectful peaceful protest will be
demonstrated again this weekend
police with the full assistance of the
city have been preparing for this
protest as you've heard this afternoon
because we all want to do everything we
can to avoid the situation that we're
seeing in ottawa
if anyone is planning to come here for a
protest that is not peaceful and that is
not respectful i would urge you on
behalf of all toronto residents and
businesses to please stay home
peaceful and respectful is the way we do
things here
overnight and this morning i've had
calls from prime minister trudeau public
safety minister mendocino and premier
ford
in our conversations all three offered
their help
and the help of their governments to the
city of toronto if required throughout
this protest
i'm thankful for their offers of support
and for their commitment to helping us
to protect the public safety of all of
our residents and businesses
i know the road closures put in place
over the course of the weekend may be
disruptive to some residents and
businesses but as the police have said
the chief has said this is about public
safety in general and protecting our
hospitals and everyone who works there
and seeks care there
all of these measures are focused on
public safety
i want again to be absolutely clear that
i support toronto police taking
necessary action to prepare for this
protest with a focus on doing everything
they can to protect the safety of
toronto residents and businesses and to
minimize any disruptions to toronto
residents and businesses to the greatest
extent possible
to
the residents of toronto understand that
people should not be blocked from
receiving emergency care or any medical
care and hospital workers should be able
to freely and safely come and go from
their workplaces
i know toronto residents are also
thinking about all the businesses that
will be open this weekend for the first
time since public health measures were
updated the first weekend since they
were updated particularly restaurants
that will be open for indoor dining
these businesses which have been hit
very hard by the pandemic have every
right to be open and not to be disrupted
as mayor i don't direct the police no
elected official does or should but i
have made it clear to chief reimer that
i will support his men and women doing
everything they can reasonably do to
avoid the type of situation currently
being faced by ottawa residents and
businesses
no matter what comes i know we will get
through this weekend and i want to thank
toronto residents and businesses in
advance for their patience and
understanding with these developments
and for their cooperation with the
toronto police service and other public
officials
everyone's been through a lot over the
course of this pandemic but i know
people understand the paramount
importance of public safety
i also want to thank all of the police
officers led by our very capable and
reliable chief of police james raymer
and the city staff who are working
throughout this weekend to keep our city
and all of its residents safe
we want to keep them safe as well the
officers who are doing this work for us
this is a great city and like all cities
around the world we've battled the covet
19 pandemic for the last two years and i
know that's been tremendously hard on a
lot of people maybe most people
but we're almost through this pandemic
and we're at this point thanks to the
collective efforts and cooperation of
the vast majority of toronto residents
more than 90 percent of toronto
residents have their first dose of
vaccine today 60 percent of eligible
residents have their third dose
what great demonstrations of the unity
of the people of this city of teamwork
of concern for each other
and we're on the path to reopening
so we will get there and we will come
back stronger than ever i'm completely
confident that will be the case and i'm
here to provide whatever support that i
can
to all of the men and women who will be
working hard to keep this city its
people and its businesses safe
over the course of this weekend
thank you
well now take questions when you called
palm please your mic at this time only
please can you also indicate who your
question is for chief james raymer mayor
john tory staff superintendent lauren
pogue you can ask one question and one
follow-up once you've asked your
question you'll be muted again thank you
nicole from the canadian press do you
have a question
i do um thank you my question is for
chief ramer um i'm wondering you know as
to meritori said there have been
protests throughout the pandemic against
covet measures
um what specifically
makes it so that this time you know
you're coming out with with this
enhanced plan like what is it that sets
this apart
well it's uh that's a good question the
um
when you look at uh recent events and
the type of demonstrations that are
going around the country and and then
based on the intelligence information
we're receiving from our partners across
the province
uh we're trying to ensure that we have
an uh
events and demonstrations going on in
the city
that
will
and we will make every attempt to
facilitate peaceful assembly
but at the same time we want to make
sure that we protect the public we
protect our emergency services we
protect our hospitals
and given some of the information
that we've received we feel that these
steps are appropriate
you have a follow-up nicole
nicole do you have a follow-up
we'll come back to you nicole
next up is mark from 680 news do you
have a question
do you have a question
mark i think you're having some sound
difficulties at your side
okay we'll go to uh
jackie next at cp24 jackie do you have a
question
you can go ahead
if you're having technical issues or you
can't hear us please submit your
questions over the chat and we'll read
them out for you
fioza from the new york times
if you can mute yourself and you may ask
a question
fiose you can
mute yourself
we'll come back to you we have a
question from wendy gillis at the star
to what extent has the protest in ottawa
helped toronto prepare for this weekend
has the service studied what went well
and what hasn't worked and that's for
you chief james romer
yes um actually uh we we always
examine and debrief events going around
in our own jurisdictions and around the
country with our policing partners and
our subject matter matter experts and so
when we we look to prepare the next
event
uh that we have to address we take all
the the learnings from each of those
events past events and and try to ensure
that we can do things better more safely
and
with the public's protection in mind so
yes we do learn from each and every
event
that's uh
we use those to prepare for
thank you and do you have a follow-up
wednesday
we have a question from mark douglas at
ct news question for chief bremer
our full-sized buses on university
avenue meant to prevent 18 wheelers from
breaking through
yeah those are uh
the vehicles we use are events special
event buses
we've used those for a number of years
and
quite frankly they're larger they take
up more space and require less vehicles
they just prove to be a better
uh way to block streets and and
different outcomes and and it's
something we've been utilizing for the
last
oh i think probably the last six seven
years we've used those buses
thank you we have a question from viosa
the new york times this question is for
staff superintendent lauren pogue
can please provide any additional
details as to the number of officers
uniformed or otherwise types of units
cruisers etc on the streets
and then she does have a follow-up
question which i'll ask to mayor john
tory after
thank you
while we have
addressed that we do have many resources
who are available for the protest this
weekend i won't be commenting on these
specific units or the number of officers
or the areas that they generally police
at this time thank you
and her follow-up to medjontory can you
tell us whether the city will deploy any
bylaw enforcement for infractions such
as noise by laws and how that effort
will be staffed
well our staff of people who
enforce the bylaws and who educate
people with respect to the bylaws are on
duty all the time as they will be on
duty this weekend and again this is a
coordinated operation between the city
and the police service and a lot of
those decisions made about about law
enforcement are made in conjunction with
one another but certainly those
directions are not given from
politicians to the law by law
enforcement officers either so i'm sure
that they'll be out doing their job as
they always are and if they're required
to be doing any specific aspect of their
job related to uh these events that
we're planning for they'll get that
direction i'm sure from the police
service and from their own superiors
within the city administration
thank you
and we have a follow-up question from
nicole
at the canadian press she asked what
measures will the police service use if
the situation starts to devolve and
that's to chief james arena
well that that
really speaks to planning and and uh
and a very robust planning that we do
have in place to to address uh
a number of potential existences it's
very much a fluid and very dynamic
situation
and uh what i will say to you is that it
requires us to be nimble and agile and
have to adapt and so uh at the end of
the day i can't speak to specific
strategies uh nor will i frankly it's
just simply to know that uh we are
examining a number of contingencies and
and uh
we will adapt to address uh
what we're presented with and and we
will try our very best to uh address
public safety and and and
reduce or have minimal disruption to the
entire city
thank you and wendy gillis has her final
follower
what will the service do if there are
protesters who come and park their
vehicles and refuse to leave as we've
seen in ottawa and that also is for
cheap james raymond
we're actually uh have some strategies
in place where we're going to
we are going to encourage
strongly encourage
areas where
people can stage vehicles where they
will cause minimal disruption
and if they're in if their intention is
to demonstrate then they can
travel by foot or public transit to
queen's park and they can demonstrate uh
in person
but uh vehicles will not be congregating
around queen's park and we're going to
like i say try to afford places where
people can stage your vehicles where
there'll be minimal disruption
thank you i believe mark douglas has
reconnected so mark if you're there do
you want to ask your follow-up question
connie thank you i just want to confirm
first of all everyone can uh can hear me
now
yes we can
thank you connie thank you uh glad to
have everyone uh back online here at the
webex meeting uh question for uh police
chief ramer uh i'm looking right now
with the blo at the barricades at
college and university full-size buses
are being set up here in the north and
south end of the of the legislature
building
are have such large vehicles been
brought in for the barricade
as a fear of an 18-wheeler truck
possibly ramming through a smaller
barricade and charging the building
no i i
i mentioned earlier that we went to this
type of
planning several years ago where we were
using the buses uh there as you can tell
they're painted the service colors
uh and they have special events planning
and we use them to block roadways on a
regular basis and it's it's quite
frankly rather than two police cars uh
we can use a bus and so that's why
they're there to obstruct or not to
obstruct but to impede and block traffic
for safety purposes
thank you
and the follow-up question to you as
well uh chief framer there have been a
few a few posts on social media but i'm
thinking of one particularly by mpp
randy hillier showing gas cans and
explosive shells in reference to the
convoy tomorrow are these posts being
considered as any type of terrorism type
threat
um
what i will say and it's a good question
thank you what i will say is that we are
engaged with all our partners across the
province examining social media all in
intelligence that is available and based
on the information we have we will
respond
and to ensure public safety
thank you and we'll go to our last
reporter now uh jackie jackie crandall's
from cp24 do you want to ask your
question
i think an apologies if any of these
questions are redundant i haven't been
able to to listen in much i have a
question about how long you'll let the
um the protesters stay you've seen
obviously in ottawa that they're
sticking around um you know the issue of
vehicles aside if they're able to get in
on foot and you know large numbers of
them can do that how do you control that
type of crowd and how long do you let
them stay if their intention is to stay
uh okay thanks uh jackie for that i uh
we'll we'll assess the event as it goes
i mean if people are on foot and they're
demonstrating around queen's park
usually these will go on for a number of
hours and and then
we'll be looking to
see the people move on and and we'll
work with the crowds and the organizers
and trying to facilitate a peaceful
protest but our intention is that
these areas will not be used for people
to encamp or
stay permanently for any duration of
time
and do you have a follow-up jackie
i do yeah the residential areas
surrounding queen's park and you know
just in the downtown core in general um
in terms of
noise and disruption to those areas um
how are you going to keep people from
entering those residential areas again
we've seen that happen in ottawa we've
seen the disruption to the people who
live
near the area where they're sort of
taking a space in ottawa if that's
what we see happen in toronto how are
you going to minimize disruption to
people who
call the downtown core the surrounding
area around its park home
uh we are
very aware of of some of the uh
activities that have taken place uh in
ottawa as you've referenced and and uh
very we've very much taken uh
those things into consideration and are
forming part of our strategy
um and so what i will say is that we are
going to try to do our best
to to prevent that type of action and
and to ensure there's minimal disruption
that is our goal
thank you and before the conclusion we
just have one final question from wendy
gillis at the start
she's wondering where the staging
grounds the teeth mentioned are located
and are they in the city
there are going to be a few places
around the city at wendy
i can't speak to where they are
specifically now but our teams are
in conversation with organizers and
discussing those particular locations
thank you and that concludes today's
conference thank you for joining us
okay